he's a longtime radio analyst for that
organization and a Pro Football Hall of
Famer who's been there done that at the
collegiate level as well as the pros one
of our favorites warren moon good to see
you back here and you see you're rich
are you doing what do you make out of
last night's season opener I think
Kansas City caught a New England at the
right time you're looking at a team that
has a ton of new faces on that football
team you look at what's happened with
football in general the amount of time
these guys don't spend on the field
anymore so they don't get a chance to
really come together and and get to know
each other and get to know the system
the way they need to because of the way
the rules have changed they're not
allowing you to be on the field as early
in the off-season coaches are so worried
about injuries are not playing their
players a lot during the preseason so
these guys don't get a chance to play a
lot together and it showed last night
New England look like a team that had a
lot of different faces on offense which
it does and a lot of different faces on
defense which it does and in Kansas City
take advantage of this so so why would I
guess Kansas City has some some new
faces I mean there hasn't been as well
as much turnover on either side of a
football but a whole damn new Alex Smith
showed up last night what was that
surprising to you that's it was
surprising that he was taking the shots
down the field but what wasn't
surprising was well the more surprising
thing was how open those receivers were
down the field and I think that's what
made Alex take these shots when you see
receivers running that open down the
field you've got to take those shots
down the field because those are huge
plays for your football team where in
the past I don't think Alex had that
type of speed that he has now with the
Tyreke he'll with the with the the young
kid he'll with a Rhema cream cream hunts
yeah with with these two guys with the
speed that they have and some of the
other guys they have Connolly on the
outside they have a lot more speed and
they've had in the past so there's a lot
more separation in those routes now and
I think alex is feeling more comfortable
about taking those shots down the field
and then if the the league tries to
adjust to that speed outside I mean they
got they got their own monster 87 and
run up the seam and do all sorts of
stuff with Travis Kelce yeah they did a
nice job on him last night I think they
probably focused on him a little bit too
much and it allowed those other guys to
make big plays well Belichick takes away
the one thing you're out at the most
right now maybe we learned that they
covet hunt inhale a little bit more
often well there's a few more weapons on
this Kansas City team that they've had
in the past
and and they run the ball very well so
that's something you've got to worry
about and I think everybody was worried
when Spencer where went down with the
knee injury they're starting running
against us yeah but now this this kid
comes in here hunt and it looks like
they haven't missed a beat so you're not
worried about the New England Patriots
yeah you all know okay but I'm not as
worried as everybody else because I know
more than any other team in this league
Bill Belichick and that staff is gonna
make the adjustments that it takes to to
get this team back on track they're
gonna have a tough time going down in
New Orleans this weekend against the
drew Brees in that in the Superdome
because he gives you a lot of problems
too throwing the football he's gonna put
a lot of pressure on you they're gonna
score points and if that defense gets
excited in that in that building it
could be another long day so next week
is gonna be more of a test to me what do
they do with these next 10 days yeah to
get ready for this football game
warren moon here on the Rich Eisen show
ok so you know what it takes to be a
forty-year-old and succeed in this
league and and it really is just a
number because you know when you're 39
you're pretty damn close to 40 the same
aches and pains that you're gonna have
waking up as a 40 year old you're most
likely gonna have a 30 what he just
means so much in our society it does
does it so I become a middle-aged man
yes you do so what did you see on a
brady last night that might be the
indication of age at all wow he just did
not look sharp last night to me he
missed a lot of guys open he missed a
lot of guys that he was trying to make a
lot of back shoulder throws that he's
used to making and his balls didn't seem
to have a lot of zip on him to me I
don't know if that's just something that
I was seeing a lot of floating balls
down the field where it wasn't a lot of
driving of the football 44% for Tom
Brady and I got a football game on that
many attempts that's just not him and it
wasn't like Kansas City has this great
secondary with all these great cover
guys and they they actually lost a
couple of guys in the secondary and had
to go with some backups and he still
couldn't make plays down the field now I
know he lost you know a couple of
receivers but he still had drunk out
there he still had cooked out there he
still had
what's the other thing you got Amendola
you've got hurt Hogan Hogan yeah I mean
you still had three good receivers on
the field still wasn't able to make
plays well the thing to me that that
that struck me is the all-time greatest
quarterback sneaker that I've seen is
Tom Brady with the wood they had they
had four different short yardage
situations too long fourth downs and not
a single time did they have him sneak it
and I was wondering if that might be the
indication of okay
he's now 40 and we don't want to have
him use that what do you think usually
when they have the quarterback snake
it's usually down the goal line that's
when he usually does those on from the
one he'll jump over and come back so he
didn't surprise me that they didn't use
him in the short yardage out on the
field that's one of the reasons why they
brought in Gillings Lee and some of the
other guys for those situations but that
comes offensive line play when you let
penetration come through and don't allow
your back to get to the line of
scrimmage that's offensive line play
more so than anything did you want to
get hit less when you got older Emily
nobody wants get hit at the quarter of X
but right but yeah you want to get hit
less of course but I didn't mind doing a
quarterback sneak I didn't even mind
taking off and running if I had to it at
that age because I mean when you're out
there playing football you're not even
thinking about stuff like that you're
just thinking about making plays and I
don't think Tom is thinking about that
the coaches might think about it on the
sidelines but when you're out there
you're not gonna think about that when
you're trying to get a first down okay a
Warren Moon here on the Rich Eisen show
so ask him the poll question that
Brockman go for it
yeah or are the Patriots on to New
Orleans or or done as a Super Bowl
contender oh they're not done they are
on to New Orleans but we'll see what
happens in New Orleans like you don't
see me it's more of what's gonna happen
in New Orleans in the next the first
three games of this season I basically
tell every team around this league what
their season is gonna be like to me the
first three games it's not after one
game and not even after two games and
what about the Chiefs then what did we
learn did we learn that they are
courageous because there's a thing now
okay the reason why we're asking this
poll question
is what I saw last night with the
Patriots I saw an AFC East champion
based on other the rest of their
neighborhood let's put it that way okay
I still think they're winning this
division but I see a team that might be
playing wildcard weekend okay
because defensively they might not be
able to get 1213 wins this season based
on that but enough wins to win that
division certainly within the division
and so that's what I saw last night and
with the Chiefs they now have in their
back pocket a win that would make Tom
Brady get on a plane to play a playoff
game in their house right which is a
different ball of wax
so that that is what would concern me
after what I saw last night I know that
you can make fixes but I don't know how
many fixes you can make to get back to
that Superbowl caliber 1314 win by week
type team that got everybody's got to
come to Foxborough to play well you got
to remember a few years ago they went
into Kansas City and I think they got
beat something like 41 to 7 that's the
honest Cincinnati game that's what we're
seeing there on to New Orleans yeah and
everybody was going what's wrong with
Tom Brady what's wrong with this with
the Patriots and what do they do they
went on and I think they won the Super
Bowl that year they did and they won
another one last year right so that's
why I say don't wring the panic button
too quickly because this team knows how
to make adjustments they have one of the
best coaching staffs in the league and
they'll they'll find find the fixes they
need to make all right I want to take a
break come back as I told you I had the
Patriots versus Seattle I always just I
just feel it a Super Bowl rematch in the
football gods hands okay I'd love to see
it I think I'd be there : I know in
Minnesota
and so you call Seattle Seahawks games
on the radio I want to talk to you about
their running game and their readiness
and just in that locker room and
obviously Michael Bennett being in the
news and and and all that stuff Warren
Moon Pro Football Hall of Famer is here
you're on the phone at 8:40 for 204
which stay on hold well we will give a
an injury update on folks like Amendola
and Hightower and Odell Beckham for week
number one Warren Moon is here on the
Rich Eisen show and you should be too
don't you dare move
Warren Moon the Huskies are taking on
Montana this yeah right nervous about
Montana coming up to your house I'm not
nervous I think what our team has
understands now they're they're not the
hunter anymore they're being hunted by
everybody I think I saw that last week
in Rutgers that Rutgers now has great
respect for the Washington program
because they were in the playoff last
year and they've got a really ranch up
there their intensity when they play
against people cuz they're gonna get
everybody's best now because they're
considered one of the better teams in
the country well your eye be peeled on
Stanford USC Ducey County that would be
a really good game that'll be a physical
game a lot of great athletes out there
Stanford hasn't missed a beat it seems
like with these two running backs they
have to even though they lost McCaffrey
David does a great job up there and and
they got that physical running game
you've got to deal with it you know now
and I said this in our number one after
seeing what the Kareem hunt did with the
you know matchup problems and running
the ball against New England Carolina's
going in there in a couple weeks
I mean what's McCaffrey gonna do and
they've got to take on Alvin Kamara I
mean there's a lot of ton of great young
rookie running backs that create matchup
problems is that the way that that this
league is going do you think that
Atlanta did it with their guys in Tevin
Coleman and Devonta Freeman and you saw
New England do it too yeah with all the
James White and Rex Burkhead now this is
a copycat league so when they see teams
having success within the two teams in
the Super Bowl both had success with it
you got to see other teams trying to
emulate that what's the running game
looking like for Seattle
the Seahawks it's gonna be a running
game by committee Eddie Lacy's gonna be
the guy who's gonna get the bulk of the
carries I would think as long as he
stays healthy and that's what Pete wants
he wants a big physical running game
kind of like what he had with Marshawn
Lynch I think with Thomas Rawls getting
healthier Supercuts that's his nickname
well be a guy that can you really give
you some quality carries after that and
then CJ Prosise is the guy who they want
to use a lot is a receiver out of the
backfield third down back who could also
run the football and then we have this
young kid Chris Carson who had a great
preseason and he made our football team
a rookie from Oklahoma State he runs
physical and he runs just how people
wants his running backs to run so I
think we have four guys depth wise they
can really
help our footballs so how many touches
for Eddie Lacy I mean what do you think
you'd like to see him get somewhere in
the 15 to 20 20 carry range if he can if
he can hold up like that but when you
have it like I said a Thomas Rawls who's
really shown that he can be good in this
league if he stays healthy right now
you've got another guy who can get
another 10 carries we want to run the
football a little bit more than we did
last year okay now I we had Doug Baldwin
on the show the other day love that guy
great we had Earl Thomas on the show
last year after he hurt himself and
asked him hey you know you tweeted out
you were gonna retire I mean you're not
really thinking of that and just two
weeks later he's like you bet I'm still
thinking about it
meaning you've got Richard Sherman and
obviously Michael Bennett we're gonna
talk about him in a moment you've got a
lot of guys kam chancellor on this team
who are strong willed strong mind if it
goes right and it seems to me that Pete
Carroll just winds him up nice and tight
and just lets him loose against the rest
of the National Football League is that
what he is that what his philosophy yes
it really is and it starts in practice
in the beginning of the week I mean they
have the most competitive practices I've
ever been around
they get after each other they push each
other they call each other names but
then they're brothers when it's when
it's all said and done so it starts in
practice he lets these guys be
themselves personality-wise he lets them
talk about the things they need to talk
about but as long as they don't cross
the line that's when he has to reel him
back in and we've seen at times guys
have crossed the line and he's had to
reel him back in like Richard Sherman
talking about the play Colin last year
and it had to be called to the carpet
and Richard understands and he's fine
now and I think everything has moved
along even though it took a little bit
longer than most people thought to get
over those feelings well how does he
doubt his Pete Carroll do that right
because again when you wind him up and
nice and tight sometimes they before you
lute let them loose up against the rest
of the league they kind of cannibalize
in a way just Joe for his team and a
good feel for his leadership on the team
and how does he and a lot of it he lets
the leadership handle a lot of
before he gets involved like like a cam
Chancellor cam has a tremendous respect
in that locker room and there's so many
leaders like you talked about like
Michael Bennett all those guys have
tremendous voices in that locker room so
when they talked the other players on
the team listen and they're gonna
control that locker room until you know
Pete sees that maybe he needs to step in
and make something happen himself but he
lets those guys take care of that locker
room and then do you know again this is
take this out as you will in the middle
of all this as a quarterback that for
the lack of a better analogy he's like
Bambi amongst the wolves right in
Russell Wilson is that in a a fair
assessment that yeah he's not Bambi but
he's not the guy that you're gonna he's
not giving those none of those big pep
talks from or he's not gonna chastise
any guys on the team but he's gonna do
the things leadership wise that you want
your quarterback to do as far as taking
care of business you know when the team
goes out on the field that he's going to
be as prepared as anybody he's gonna set
the standard as far as how you should
practice and things like that he's not
gonna let practices ever get laxed or
anything like that so he's a leader in
another type of way and then they have
other leaders for for other things on
the foot and it just works in this been
working and as long as it works
don't don't fix it so what about you
know I guess again we when we had dug
ball one on how many times did he say
the word compete or competitor I mean I
said I mean I watch it every day they
they do it live it every day and and
I've never seen anything like it and
I've been around a lot of football teams
for a long time to see how those guys go
at it warren moon here in the Rich Eisen
show I I love the Giants defense this
year and I love that offense if Odell is
healthy okay you like their offensive
line that's the problem
I don't okay and that's one of the
reasons why I asked you about Seattle's
run game first and their offensive line
right that is part of the reason why add
a little bit of hitch in my giddyup
because inevitably the Seattle Seahawk
offensive season has that four to six
week moment where he where Daryl bevels
offense looks horrible
or Russell's not thrown it on time and
he's running around for his life because
the offensive line can't protect him or
he thinks he needs to run around for his
life instead of hitting the guy and
timing precisely
and that's when Richard Sherman starts
going nutty right I mean most of this
happened last year but in here before
sometimes in the era yeah what they were
in the Super Bowl that's true what why
why won't that happen this year do you
think I think this year because
Russell's healthy and and he makes up
for a lot of those maybe missed
assignments on the offensive line in the
passing game that he can make guys miss
and still make a play out of something
you don't like to see that happen a lot
and I think this offensive line will be
better this year even though we did lose
our left tackle George family I think we
have a pretty good player over there and
reso diamo he's a young guy but he's
really smart and he's really talented
he just needs that experience like the
rest of them got last year
and I think they're gonna be better up
front this year what is out what do you
think about the week one matchup
how does this play out in Green Bay what
a Gretzky it's gonna be an interesting
matchup for us we don't play well in
Green Bay we have not won there I think
since 1999 or something like that and
some of our worst losses under Pete have
been against Green Bay I think we got
beat there 3810 last year rustled those
five interceptions
you know Russell threw four
interceptions against him in the NFC
Championship game so this this isn't a
team that he's had a great success
against either so it's it's gonna be a
big test for us on the road you know if
we don't make Aaron Rodgers
uncomfortable in that pocket he can beat
he can be really dangerous back there
that's why I think Sheldon Richardson is
gonna really help us as far as an inside
passion which can be incredible you've
got to be able to get pressure on Aaron
and keep him in the pocket cuz once he
gets outside the pocket he's a very very
special quarterback as is Russell Wilson
so I think that's what the game's gonna
come down to who can make each other's
quarterback the most uncomfortable and
get them to a place where they're not
comfortable throwing the football
because those two guys are gonna have a
big impact on this game
Warren Moon here on the Rich Eisen show
I'd love to give you the floor on what
you think is going on with Michael
Bennett and how that is playing in the
locker room and how he is being very
vocal now I would say that he is the
face of NFL social activism right now
right now I would say that as well and
especially since he experienced
everything that a lot of people have
been talking about with this social
activism as far as racial inequality and
some police brutality and things like
that now of a sudden he experiences it
it really brings it home and it brings
it home to all these players around the
league that maybe they're gonna get a
little bit more involved too because
they see it happen to one of their
brothers
well Vegas police says they want an
apology the union of Vegas police say
they want an apology and an NFL
investigation the NFL said that he
hasn't violated any policy so there's no
investigation that's coming well he
hasn't I mean all he did was run from a
situation that he thought was dangerous
they thought they heard gunshots so he
runs from it um and then you end up
getting arrested for it and then let go
because there was no gunshots from what
I understand why is Jim Brown saying
that Colin Kaepernick is doing it wrong
what do you think what's going on with
Jim saying that he understands what
Colin's saying but he doesn't like the
way that he's going about it I don't
like the way he's going to ways going
about it either I think this whole thing
of of protesting the flag I mean the
flag is something that that stands we're
supposed to to abide by what the flag
stands for which is what this country
stands for as far as you know you us
being United us having freedom all the
different things that go along with
being an American that's what the flag
is a symbol of the flag didn't do
anything wrong we're the ones doing
things wrong we as people aren't doing
what we're supposed to be doing to
uphold the flag and we need to worry
about ourselves and we need to think
about ourselves and are we doing the
right things to make sure all these
things aren't happening that this flag
stands for so I don't think protesting
the flag and protesting the national
anthem should be the right way about
going about this because these players
have a platform as it is they don't need
to protest in order to get attention
they all you need to do is stand up in
front of a podium and talk about it well
and in Colin doesn't talk about it he
doesn't talk about the things that
bother him we don't we haven't heard
from Colin Kapernick in a long time
we've heard from his girlfriend we've
we've heard the tweets that she's put
out there that haven't been good
let's hear from Colin about why he's why
he wanted to do what he did last year a
little bit more have you spoken to
Michael Bennett about this yes and if
you told me he has his own opinion and
and that's why we live in this country
this is just my opinion yeah if I had
these same feelings as a quarterback all
I do all I gotta do is call press
conference and I'll get everybody to
listen to what I have to say I don't
need to protest it well we had an qualms
there are a lot of people that need to
protest because they're not gonna get
the same get the same attention that say
I would get as a professional football
player now people they go out and
protest and March do all those things I
see why they do that because they need
they need that to get that attention for
whatever it is they're they're
protesting but I don't need to do that
in order to to get the attention that I
need to bring bring attention to that
particular problem that we're talking
about well and just to finish up the
conversation we had Anquan Boldin on
after he retired to focus fully on these
issues he said that you know he was
talking about this before but nobody
started talking about it and paying
attention what he's saying until colin
kaepernick took a knee you're right so
how does we Square this whole circle of
that that nobody was talking about it
until he did actually take a knee in
front of the flag right and then yours
you see what I'm saying well yeah
because he protested it and he didn't
used the flag to do it but like I'm
saying I didn't think he needed to do it
that way but that's the way he chose to
do it that's his opinion and go along
with it but deal with the consequences
of it I'm just saying if I had a problem
with what's going on socially in the
world
I would just call the press conference
to talk about it and people would talk
and people would listen
now whether anything was done about it I
don't know but at least we'd be talking
about it and I think I think we're at
the point now where everybody knows
where everybody is so let's start
talking about solutions now as opposed
to why why do we need to keep protesting
every weekend but nobody's saying
anything about how we're gonna make this
better let's do something to make it
better when you had to Green Bay tonight
on the red-eye
you don't get the green bay any sooner
than you need today although I am gonna
have a great steak dinner tomorrow go
come on now come on now we want people
to be saying hey there's Warren moody
sitting I heard what Warren Brunetta say
about going to green meadow they've got
some great places okay
good to see you Warren to stop by please
come back that's Warren Moon at W moon 1
on Twitter with Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that download around please just if if
it's a memory thing just delete other
apps you don't need those apps this app
the Rich Eisen show up you need that